doch noch zwei tage bis zur europawahl
und wir stellen fest union und spd sind
offensichtlich nervös
zum einen wegen der umfragen und dann
diskutiert plötzlich ganz deutschland
über ein youtube video mit dem
wunderbaren titel die zerstörung der cdu
ja heute schon über sieben millionen
klicks ist unfassbar
darin rechnet der youtuber rieso mit
merkels partei ab mit ihrer klimapolitik
artikel 13 im grunde mit ihrem
lebenswerk
so wie reagierst du jetzt als
volkspartei auf diese sieben millionen
erstmal gar nicht ist ja nur youtube
dann aber hatte die cdu die großartige
idee ihren jungstar philipp am tor von
der leine zu lassen
den ältesten 26-jährigen der welt es
gibt auf der ganzen welt keinen älteren
[Applaus]
sr gegen eine pressemitteilung aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus ein antwort video
wurde angekündigt von einem herold nimm
das rieso jedoch nicht also ich habe mit
viel freude gestern im konrad adenauer
haus ein video gedreht die cdu hat sich
dann jetzt entschieden und ich finde
dass dann auch richtig zu sagen das
video und ein video mit dem anspruch
einer zerstörung das ist nicht der stil
der cdu mit den worten mein video war
scheiße und werden weggeschmissen
wir haben es gepackt und gesagt na ja
man muss sich das mal klar machen der
gigantische marketing apparat der großen
volkspartei cdu ist nicht in der lage
einem youtuber auf wenigstens zum teil
berechtigte kritik adäquat zu antworten
werde
was sagt man dazu ich verstehe nicht
warum die cdu nicht mit einem eigenen
video reagiert wollen sie auch gibt es
die arbeiten wollen sie wohlig
veröffentlicht verstehe nicht warum
nicht
ich habe selber schon überlegt ob ich da
was mache ja bitte bitte macht macht das
wir sehen das auf also bei youtube bei
youtube nicht im fernsehen wirklich
einmal lächerlich lächerlich als wäre
die cdu auf typen wie lindner angewiesen
um sich ein junger menschen
heranzuwachsen
die müssen selber wie man coole internet
spots dreht hier echter cdu sports
europawahl mit elmar brok
ja glaube wir haben es die zukunft
formel für europa sonntag wir cdu
ja ich glaube ich habe ich muss mich
wieder hinlegen schwester
fussballtransfers
normalerweise wäre es mir egal aber
solche schmach spots vor einer
schicksalswahl ja sonntag dass es eine
schicksalswahl
die rechten europa schließen sich gerade
zusammen die planen in brüssel die
größte fraktion aller zeiten wurde die
großrazzia kfd und co auch die afd will
die eu im grunde weg kam man sich
geradezu unpatriotisch finde denn keiner
profitiert so sehr vom binnenmarkt wie
wir deutschen
brüssel hat die weltweit erste strategie
gegen plastikmüll auf den weg gebracht
hat sonst keiner
roaming gebühren abgeschafft hier ein
keyboard cdu influenza rechnet für uns
nach von 100 euro die ein deutscher
erwirtschaftet gibt man die knapp 50
euro ab über abgaben gebühren steuern
und beiträge von den 50 kommt ein euro
nach europa ich wusste gar nicht dass
dieser sympathische engländer so gut
deutsch spricht das ist ja wahnsinn so
was ich mir wenn ich ein bisschen kritik
mal einbringen darf was ich mir von der
eu wünschen würde wäre mehr macht für
das europäische parlament und weniger
für die staatschefs im sogenannten
europäischen rat der
kommissionspräsident zb wird vom rat
vorgeschlagen die segnen sämtliche
kommissar ab mit anderen worten der
ganze wahlkampf timmermanns gegen weber
der überall plakatiert ist ist leider
etikettenschwindel
die europawahl 28 nationen wählen ihr
parlament aber wer wird
kommissionspräsident franz oder manfred
das entscheiden 418 millionen
wahlberechtigte nur spaß
das entscheiden diese beiden knallt
hinten im hinterzimmer über einer
billigen packung kekse europawahl jedoch
trotzdem bin ich ja nur eine these aber
wer weiß wenn der wähler den
kommissionspräsidenten wirklich
bestimmen dürfte hätten wir vielleicht
auch ein bisschen mehr
europabegeisterung wir schalten wir live
in unser heute-show wahlstudio in
brüssel zu albrecht humboldt albrecht
warum ist da nicht noch mehr euphorie
naja es ist halt so wahnsinnig schwer
sich den überblick zu verschaffen auf
den deutschen wahlzettel stehen 41
parteien wegen fehlender fünf prozent
hürde
bis man den zu ende gelesen hat ist die
nächste europawahl
allein vier parteien für tierschutz hier
die partei mensch umwelt tierschutz
bitte nicht verwechseln mit aktionen
partei für tierschutz das original oder
die allianz für menschenrechte tier und
naturschutz und natürlich die partei für
die tiere da tritt glaube ich als
spitzenkandidat dieser rauhaardackel an
und was zum henker wird die europäische
partei liebe eine forderung aus dem
wahlprogramm jedes brautpaar soll geld
für eheringe hochzeitskleid und einen
edlen hochzeitsanzug für den bräutigam
bekommen
und das soll die regierung bezahlen ja
okay das macht sinn bevor sie das geld
in berliner flughafen verbrennen krieges
hat jeder eine hochzeitskleid schön
naja man nicht alle kleinen sind ja
quatsch parteien kennen sie zb die lkr
die liberal- konservativen reformer
spitzenkandidat und ich glaube einziges
mitglied ist unser alter kumpel bernd
lucke wie diesem flugzeug geht es manch
hoch fliegenden plan aus brüssel in der
flüchtlingspolitik hat die eu die
kontrolle verloren
ich will italienerin in italien weiß ich
nicht wenn ich wählen soll
ich wünschte es gäbe bei uns einen
liberalen vernünftigen kopf wie bernd
lücke da ist liebe bernd lucke ich habe
zwar keine ahnung wird dass es aber er
hat mich 20 euro gegeben
ja das ist ja alles albern aber sagen
sie mal wie ist denn so kurz vor der
wahl deutschland standing da in brüssel
wie kommen wir so an im rest der union
super super ich meine hey wir sind die
deutschen
wann haben wir europa je geschadet ganz
im gegenteil
können sie gerne mal googeln was
deutschland als stimme der vernunft hier
in brüssel alles verhindert hat eine
digital steuer dann müsste amazon
steuern zahlen wollten die franzosen
eine einheitliche klimastrategie co2
steuer konzerne müssten offenlegen was
sie in welchem land verdienen haben
alles wir verhindert und dafür mögen uns
die anderen ja klar ist doch alles gut
für deutschland für europa
mögen die lieben uns hier
ich habe heute abend 100 reporter von
anderen europäischen ländern eingeladen
ja kleiner umtrunk unter freunden sollte
eigentlich 20 uhr losgehen weiß jetzt
gar nicht wo die alle bleiben
wahrscheinlich verkehrten
na ja da kommt jemand ach das ist nur
meine mutter mama ja kommt nimm dir ein
würstchen aber nur eins die sind alle
abgezielt die die anderen kommen
bestimmt gleich auch glaube ich auch
[Musik]
albrecht um mord bei damen und herren
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort